so i'm going to talk about quantum
computing today and just like a very
good rock concert
i hope that everyone will enjoy this
maybe we'll learn something and probably
also be a little bit confused
and if it was a good rock concert maybe
you will have some nosebleeds also we'll
see
um a little bit more about myself
so as as you heard already my name is
johnny
i'm a little active on twitter so you
can always follow me on twitter if you
have any questions
after the conference you can also ask me
on twitter i have a github page and on
this github page i have my personal
projects
and i also have all of my conference
presentations so after the con
presentation you will find all of the
resources right on my github page
and i will share a link at the end of
the presentation i work for involved it
which is a consultancy firm in belgium
and i'm actually
a software developer architect
working for involved
and this is basically.net and c-sharp
related
so what the hell am i talking about
quantum computing then
well about two years ago i was in the
same
place as you guys so i was listening to
a conference and
it had a presentation on uh quantum
computing
but i think after the presentation was
done i only got about
uh 25 of the content that i that i
really understood
so i decided to do my own talk from the
perspective of a software developer in
dot net and c sharp
um trying to make the message more clear
to people like me
so people like you i hope so my goal
today would be to
explain quantum computing and the future
of quantum computing
um to you and hopefully that you will
understand more than the 25
that i understood uh two years ago um so
it's basically a hobby i don't do it
professionally but i i want to learn
as much as i can about it if you have
any questions
next to my twitter you can always
contact me on my
company email address and that's it so
let's uh shut up about me and
dive right into the quantum computing
stuff so why in god's name would we
want quantum computing well today
it's hard to believe but today we still
have a lot of problems
um problems that we cannot solve by a
classical computer so when i
when i'm talking about classical
computers i mean the computer that
you're using at home
a laptop a pc uh your smartphone which
is all a computer but there are many
problems that cannot be solved by that
kind of
computers because the cpu in a computer
has its physical limits
maybe you noticed but the last decade
cpus didn't really get a lot
faster um we were just putting more cpus
in
in one computer basically but it's it's
it's
we are on a limit the current classical
computing architecture does not
allow us to scale it even more to be
faster to be smaller
it's it's it becomes very difficult um
but our the world where we live in is so
complex
like think of think on the about the
atomic structure of everything we
we live in it's so hard for a classical
computer to work with that
and that's why we need something new and
hopefully quantum computing can help us
solve that issue
so i have an example um of such a
problem that is quite complex for a
classical computer
and this is actually a problem that's
been described to me by a teacher in in
in elementary school so i was
i was in class and he said okay if you
have a chess board
there is a kind of a jump you can do on
a chance chessboard using um
the horse it can go eight different
directions
but if you start on a on a random spot
on the chessboard
and you make a jump you come right on
the next spot and then you do the same
jump over and over and over again until
you
you have visited all of the squares on
the chessboard without missing one
so this is a problem you can solve and i
did it on the right hand side so the
right hand side is a picture that i drew
myself it took me about a thousand years
to reach that conclusion and it's
actually the same thing with a classical
computer
if you write a brute force algorithm so
if you take out your computer
your visual studio c-sharp whatever and
you start writing an algorithm that
visits
all of these squares one by one and if
you make a mistake which means if you're
uh if you're stuck somewhere because you
can't do another jump because all of the
squares are already visited
you have to backtrack so you can write
this algorithm and if you do it
um correct it will take a few seconds
if you do it if you make the wrong
decisions by accident
in your brute f uh brute force algorithm
it can take your computer
years to find a solution and that is
just crazy
why does it take years your cpu is so
fast
that's because there are so many
permutations there's only 64 squares
but there are so many permutations for
you to visit
in a specific order so this is a problem
that to our minds looks very simple but
to a computer
is actually very hard to solve another
cool example
is something even more simple if you
take a regular piece of paper
let's find a piece of paper right here
so this is a
regular piece of paper this has a
thickness of about
0.1 millimeter so 0.1 millimeter if i
fold it double
the thickness of the paper doubles so
0.2 millimeter
and if i keep doing this 42 times so 42
is not a large number
42 it's not physically possible you can
try
i think seven or eight times is the
maximum you will you will be able to do
because you don't have enough force
but if you do it 42 times the thickness
of this piece of paper
will reach from the earth to the moon
half a million kilometers
this is again mind blowing 42 is such a
small number
it's so comprehensible but folding
something
so doubling something 42 times is just a
very large number so half a million
kilometers and this is the exact reason
why quantum computing
is something that is needed because for
classical computers it's the same thing
a problem can seem very easy but if you
just add
one small variable to the problem the
problem space
can double or exponentially increase and
your computers cannot solve this
in a thousand years so
quantum computing actually uh uses um
phenomenon from quantum physics that
that are experimentally proven
already um so it's already a 100 years
ago that scientists
knew that something weird was going on
on a subatomic level
so on the level of microscopic things
like uh
electrons or photons some weird things
are happening
and they they can't really explain why
those are happening but they have
proven by experiments that they are
happening and two of those phenomena are
superposition and entanglement
what is it all about um so superposition
first so on
a quantum level sort of very small
microscopic objects like electrons they
have specific
properties and those properties can have
a specific state so for example a spin
of an electron which is the image on the
left hand side
can be up or it can be down it's not
really something
tangible you can't really look at an
electron and see it spin it's something
that you can measure
um with experiments but we would like to
talk
uh in physics about the spin of an
electron that is in a state
up or a state down and from experiments
we can all we can also see that this
spin property can actually be
up and down in the same at the same time
and this is what what they call
superposition
so it's not really up it's not really
down it's somewhere in between
and when i'm saying um something in
between or at the same time that's not
that's also not correct
it's actually some kind of probability
thing
that says okay if you are to measure the
spin of an electron
there is some percentage is going to be
up and some percentage is going to be
down
but the electron itself did not yet make
the decision it only makes that decision
if you actually look at it if you
measure it and then it will make that
decision based on some probability
way if they call it so this is very very
difficult for
us on a macroscopic level to to to grasp
it's like you're sitting on a chair but
maybe that chair is not underneath you
maybe it's underneath
the person who's sitting next to you um
so it's very weird it does it
only works on a microscopic level so it
doesn't work in real life luckily
there's only one thing i know where it
works and it's a usb
key so if you have a usb key you want to
put it inside of your computer
it's in super position you try it one
way it doesn't work you try it the other
way it doesn't work you flip it around
couple of times
it still doesn't work you really have to
look at the orientation of your usb slot
and then when you look at it you measure
it
it takes a decision it's up or down and
then you can
safely put it inside so that's the only
thing on a macroscopic level that i
know of that actually works in this
quantum way in the superposition way
the second thing is entanglement so this
is even more weird
so if we have a an electron for example
it can be entangled to another electron
which means that if both electrons are
in superposition at the same time so
that's the image on the right hand side
they are somehow they can be somehow
entangled together which means that they
are basically
one and the same but still they're two
separate entities
and if you observe one of them it will
make the decision if
if the spin of the electron is up or
down but
weird is that the other entangled
electron will make the same decision
at the same time so you look at the left
hand side
the left electron it it decides it's
it's spin up
and then the right hand side electron
will decide it's spin down
it's always going to be the opposite and
this
scientists really don't know how this
works they they tested this on multiple
occasions
um if they send one entangled
electron to a lab at the other side of
the world and they observe it
they they are still connected but they
are so far apart
they are not communicating they also
tested this there's no
communication between them because
communication or not communication goes
faster than light because it's instant
so yeah we we really don't know uh what
the hell is going on here
some scientists think that there's like
wormholes in between of those electrons
to to
be able to make them communicate but
basically
when scientists talk about wormholes
they are just saying i have no idea
um there is an experiment um called the
double slit experiment which is very
cool but i don't have the time to
talk about it in much detail today so
during my workshop tomorrow i will
i will dig a little bit deeper into this
but you can find
videos on youtube that explain this and
this clearly explains superposition
and and the weird things that are going
on on a quantum level so i'm going to
skip this for now
um this is for example uh also something
that you can google it's called
quantum experiment at space scale and
this is what the entanglement
stuff is all about so there's actually
been an experiment where
we are using lasers from a satellite
orbiting the earth
and we're entangling two photons photon
the elementary particle of light
we're sending one to china one to
austria and those scientists really
observe one of those two photons and
they can see that
both are are collapsed so both have made
us have made a decision
one is up one is down and they really
don't know how it works
but it works so why the hell do we want
to do this crazy stuff
with our computers well basically
there's a couple of use cases for
example security
we hope that we can create algorithms
which are much
faster than classical algorithms that
can break
our current security protocols and can
create new
security protocols for us so for example
the public private key encryption
in theory can be broken by a very
powerful quantum computer but today we
don't yet
have a powerful quantum computer so we
we cannot break that
but there are uh things that quantum can
deliver us
for example quantum key distribution
where we can use entangled
articles to share passwords to or share
keys
over a quantum internet for example um
drug development is another one when i
when i talked before on
our our world we live in is quantum by
nature everything is quantum by nature
there's quantum particles inside
of you when we are developing developing
drugs
um those drugs need to work inside of
your quantum body
so why aren't we using quantum computers
to simulate a quantum system
because that should be a lot easier to
do for again for a classical computer
it is very very hard to actually
simulate
a quantum system because there's too
many variables there's too many
interactions between atoms and particles
inside of your body to actually
100 stimulate what a drug will do and
that's basically why we still do
tests on animals because we can't
for sure know what a drug does on a
human because we can't simulate
it using our classical computers so for
example gene sequencing and protein
folding are these
kind of things that you can use software
on
all of the computers in the world
working together and still it's so slow
to really find useful things for us a
third example is
for example machine learning in machine
learning we we must analyze
very large quantities of data we also
want fast feedback so
we need fast analyzing to have fast
feedback
and if we really want to emulate a human
mind that we're just going to need a lot
more power to do that
so again we hope with quantum computing
we can actually
um leverage that power from our quantum
world
so finally um why we need quantum
computers maybe the the biggest question
and i know that everyone is already
asking this question
can it run crisis so can my quantum
computer run crisis
well the answer is probably yes
but why so what i want to talk about
with
this is a quantum computer is just
another kind of computer
and quantum computers are never going to
replace our
classical computers so your classical
computer is very good in
doing classical things like for example
running crisis
if you want to play a computer game you
can do that on a classical computer
a quantum computer that will do very
good
for very specific problems and in theory
the the the kind of architecture that we
already have today for quantum computing
is compatible with classical computers
meaning that we can run every every
classical algorithm
on a quantum computer but it's going to
be really expensive because a
quantum computer is very hard to to
build it's very hard to keep running
because today it needs to be cooled down
to zero
the temp absolute zero temperature which
is very expensive
it's also very volatile so it's very
hard to
to actually run long-running algorithms
so in theory it can be done but in
practice we
we will not do it and we will only use
quantum computers for very specific
problems
that they can solve uh exponentially
faster than classical computers
also if in the future we're going to do
uh quantum computing it's
i think always going to be a classical
computer and a quantum computer working
together
so you're going to have a a classical
part of your algorithm that's going to
work
in conjunction with a quantum part of
your algorithm that both will run on
classical and quantum computers side by
side
so um i'm going to dig a little bit
deeper in
into how this actually works and then
later on in the presentation i will show
you an example in a quantum programming
language from microsoft which is called
q
sharp so the first thing you need to
know is that quantum computers actually
work the same way as classical computers
we are going to represent bits both
in classical and in quantum computers so
a bit for a classical computer is just
zero and one like everyone knows
and we can combine these bits into uh
bigger numbers
and for example here we have one zero
zero one one zero
on a quantum computer we're going to do
the same thing we're going to represent
the two states
zero and one we're going to write it
down a little bit
different just so we know that we're
talking quantum so there's going to be
like a vertical line
in the beginning of the zero and then a
a bracket and yet
at the end um this will just tell us
it's a
quantum state zero and not just the
classical state zero this is actually
called the dirac notation
um named after a mathematician called
paul dirac
and he invented this kind of notation
for quantum specifically
so the same thing zero and one zero in
quantum is zero in classical one in
quantum is one in classical
we can also combine um those those
qubits
into a combined quantum state and it's
again the same thing as classical so one
zero zero one one zero
with the direct notation to define that
this is a quantum state and not a
classical state
so the the interesting
thing here is that if we talk about
superposition and superposition is the
thing that will give the power to
quantum computer
the computing that we need to be able to
specify
this kind of probability
wave between how much probability do i
have to collapse to zero and how much
probability do i have to collapse to one
so we're going to do this mathematically
so if you want to dig deep into quantum
computing you're going to have to need a
little bit of math
um you don't have to be afraid of math
um the math used in quantum computing
looks very difficult but it's actually
quite
uh simple and i had the experience the
past two years
i was a bit afraid of math and today i
can say that it really helped me
understand everything so basically when
we talk about
a superposition state we're talking
about some
alpha value and some beta value and they
will
describe the probability of it being
zero or one
there's also a kind of normalization
formula that says that the absolute
value of alpha squared plus the absolute
value of beta squared should always
equal one
which and the one actually means that
there's always one hundred percent
probability that the both probabilities
added together
will be 100 of course um so
then things become complex literally
because the alpha and the beta values
are not just real numbers it's not just
a percentage it can actually be a
complex number so if you remember from
school complex numbers
are numbers that contain a real number a
and c
and they have an imaginary number b and
d because i
squared equals minus one or something um
something you need to know in the back
of your head that
when we calculate with quantum we really
have to calculate with complex numbers
um that's all that i'm going to say
about that um
if i do the calculations correctly and i
have a perfect superposition state so my
usb
key it can only be upside upside down or
the correct way
so it's zero or one so it's two states
if i am in superposition perfect
superposition fifty percent up fifty
percent down
then i actually mathematically have to
think about one over square root of two
is my probability
because the formula from before said
that alpha squared plus beta squared
should equal one
and 1 over square root of 2 squared is 1
over 2 or
half plus 1 over square root of 2
squared
is half so half plus half so this
really describes for me a quantum state
that's in perfect superposition fifty
percent collapsing to zero fifty percent
collapsing
to one and now things become interesting
if we do a little bit a recap we see
that a classical bit can be
zero a quantum bit can be same zero but
in the direct notation the same for one
in superposition we have those two
values alpha and beta
which describe the probability of those
states those are also complex numbers to
make things more complex
to unintended um very important that the
value is known after measurement so when
you put a qubit in a quantum computer in
superposition you can't look at it
the moment you look at it it will make
the decision if it's zero or one based
on the probability
um so
if we would look at this more
graphically because maybe that's that's
easier to do you can see i hear a sphere
and this sphere is actually called a
block sphere and this helps us
to map the state of a single qubit in
three-dimensional space
so basically you you should think of the
state of a qubit as a vector
in this space originating in the center
of the three axis x
y and z so there's a vector from here to
somewhere
on the surface of the sphere and on the
right hand side
you can see a vector which is direct
notation of psi
and psi is just a arbitrary quantum
state so it can be a
qubit in superposition it is a qubit in
superposition
and that vector can actually move around
the sphere all over the surface
which means that there's a lot of data
we can actually store inside of a single
qubit
because the alpha and beta value they
only have to
adhere to that normalization formula but
those two values can actually be
whatever they want
the result of that normalization formula
should just be one
which means there's an infinite amount
of possibilities
for different kinds of superpositions
you can have so there's a lot of data
inside of a single qubit
just going to skip this one and come
back to this later
so if we look at this systems if we
add a single qubit to a quantum state
we're actually going to have four values
now because if you look at the classical
thing
one bit can actually describe two
numbers
zero and one but two bits can describe
four numbers
zero zero zero one one zero one one
and here is now the power of quantum
computer because we can now have four
states with only two qubits
we can have a probability that it's
going to collapse to one of those four
states
and if it's a perfect superposition each
state will have a probability of 25
percent
but it's still a lot of data that's
being stored in those two qubits because
we have
four complex numbers four complex values
and if we add
another qubit to that system now we have
eight
complex values and which with each qubit
we add to that system
we're actually doubling doubling the
amount of of state we can store
within that system so basically when we
have an exponentially
large problem it's very hard to
solve that on a classical computer
because we can't
increase the speed of a classical cpu
exponentially
if you have a very powerful cpu and
it's made out of a billion transistors
if you just add one transistor to that
to that to that architecture it's going
to be
slightly faster but you're almost not
going to notice the difference
for a quantum computer that's very
different if you have a computer say
let's say
100 cubits if you want to make that
system twice as powerful you only have
to add one qubit to that system
and now it's twice as powerful so this
exponential
exponentiality will hopefully help us to
create really powerful computers
because we just need to add one basic
building block for a quantum computer
which is something that can represent
the qubit we only have to add one
to double the power of that computer
system
um so before i go
into q sharp or the
the the programming language from
microsoft i'm going to
tell you that lots of these things that
we're doing in quantum today
um are actually very mathematical in
nature
also when we are writing computer
programs um in
like c-sharp or java um we're doing this
on a
really high level so we're talking
almost english to our computer to make
us do something
for quantum which is quite young um we
are actually still doing things very
basic
so think of quantum as really writing
circuits so if you
would write a circuit for a classical
computer it's using gates like and
or not for quantum it's the same thing
so we're actually using quantum gates
but the issue is for classical computers
when you think about classical
gates and you think for example a
an and gate and you put two bits inside
of your end gate
you just from the top of your head you
can immediately say what the result is
going to be
so that's not very hard to do but for
quantum it's different because
when you have a quantum state that's in
superposition it and its probabilities
between multiple output states and then
you put that through
a quantum gate it's very hard to do from
the top of your head because there's so
many
so many mathematics behind that
that's why this slide actually tells you
that there's another way to represent
a state in the quantum world and it's uh
it's linear algebra it's matrices
so if you look at the left hand side and
you can see the direct notation for the
zero state
on the bottom you can see a matrix that
represents the zero state and on the
right hand side you can see a matrix
that represents the one state
and thanks to these matrices we can
actually use
a piece of paper or some some software
on your
pc that can do mathematical calculations
we can calculate the result
based on the gates we use for quantum
computing
so this is for example um a gate
in a quantum world that is probably the
most easy gate for you to comprehend
and it's the gate that flips a bit from
one to zero and from zero to one
so also in in quantum computing we can
have
gates that work on a classical level so
if you have a quantum state zero and you
put that state through an x-gate
you will actually flip the state around
and you can also see the same thing on
the block sphere so the block sphere
if your qubit state is zero
it's going to be a vector that points up
upwards the z-axis and if it's one it
will point downwards the z-axis
so if you do an x operation so an x-gate
it will just rotate the state of that
qubit
around the x-axis in the bloch sphere
and that will flip it from one to zero
or from zero to one
and if you want to do the calculations
you can use this matrix on the right
hand side to actually
multiply this matrix with the state
matrix of your qubit
this is an inverse identity matrix so it
will just reverse the one and the zero
in the matrix
i'm giving you um the other state so
it's very easy to work with if you know
a little bit of linear algebra
so there's other um there's other gates
that you can use there's the y
gate it will flip around the y-axis and
this uses i
so here complex numbers are really
involved
then there's the z-gate which which will
flip a cubit around the z-axis
and then there's more complicated gates
the h gate is the gate that puts a qubit
in superposition or gets a cubit out of
superposition
so in in this block sphere you can see a
vector pointing
up will be in state zero if we put it
through the
h gate or hadamard gate we will put it
in superposition
so it's going to be a rotation around a
diagonal axis
shared between the z and the x-axis and
the result will be
in front on the positive side of the
x-axis and this is actually
superposition
why because a vector is now actually
positioned
on the plane in between the zero and the
one state and this is perfect
superposition because now we have a
fifty percent chance of that vector
collapsing to
the zero state in the top or fifty um
collapsing to the one state in the
bottom
if your vector is located not on this
plane but somewhere
above or below you can see that the
probabilities are different so if the
vector is pointed up
there's going to be a higher probability
of it collapsing to zero
if the vector is pointed down there's
going to be a higher probability of it
collapsing to one and this is basically
what quantum computing is all about
we are going to have a number of qubits
we're going to put them in superposition
or even entangle them together
we're going to force those qubits to be
in some kind of superposition with some
kind of probability
that works in our benefit and then we're
going to do measurements
and hopefully that probability will
actually work in our benefit
and the result of our of our algorithm
or circuit
will resolve our problems and this is of
course something that's very difficult
here
you really need to have a deep knowledge
of how this all works
to actually make sense of that and
create useful
algorithms
so let's do some examples so first
there's ibm q experience
i'm just going to very quickly show this
to you because i think
this is just very cool if you want to
learn about quantum
so ibm built actual quantum computers so
they have running quantum computers and
you can actually use them so on the
right hand side
in my screen you can see a number of
quantum computers and you can see that
they're actually having a queue so when
you
submit your algorithm you have to wait
in the queue for that uh quantum
computer to solve your issues
but these quantum computers are not very
powerful they are
they are they can be used to do learning
or investigation
but they only have five qubits as you
can see so if you want to create an
algorithm
it's going to be very visually so you
can actually have a visual interface
that shows you three qubits and then a
whole lot of these
quantum gates or quantum operations that
you can do so for example if i
drag and had a marked gate on top of a
qubit
the first qubit in the bottom you will
see that
we now have uh three bits zero zero zero
and zero zero one
because i only used the top bit and we
have a fifty percent chance of
my bit collapsing to zero and a fifty
percent chance of it collapsing to one
because we put it in superposition
if i take it out of superposition again
we now have 100 chance of it collapsing
to zero because it's zero because we put
it in superposition and back out of
superposition
so this is how that works so with this
you can basically drag
quantum gates on top of your qubits
from left to right which represents the
time of your algorithm so you will start
on the left hand side and you can do one
operation after the other until you
reach your final end result
if you're really doing useful algorithms
at the end of your algorithm
you really have to measure your end
result which will then be
calculated into a classical zero bit
for this specific case
you can also use multiple qubits so if i
drag this hadamard gate
on top of the second qubit we now have a
two qubit system and both qubits are in
superposition
which means i have a 25 chance of them
collapsing to zero zero zero one one
zero and one one
and you can of course continue by
putting more qubits in superposition
to have your probability spread out over
more
quantum states so this is very fun to
to do things with just to to learn about
what different things you can do there's
lots of examples of existing algorithms
and you can try to recreate those
algorithms using this tool
so i just wanted to show you the visual
representation of what a quantum circuit
looks like so i have
added this link in my slide so you can
actually visit
to see the result so now microsoft they
did the same thing
but a little less visually so i'm going
to show you
visual studio code so microsoft has a
quantum
development kit which means that they
have created their own programming
language and the tools for you to
use that programming language um you can
use it from visual studio or visual
studio code it's up to you
it's just if you install the sdk it will
be available in visual studio code and
visual studio automatically
so if i'm using visual studio code so i
can open my commands palette
i can say i want to create a new q sharp
project so q sharp is the quantum
language from microsoft
it should ask me what kind of q sharp
application i want to create i want to
create a
standalone console application so
console application actually means
that it's going to run in a simulated
environment on my own pc so not on a
real quantum computer
and it's going to be a console
application that i can run to see my
simulated result
you can also do unit testing in quantum
the same way as we we know in our
classical programming languages
and you can create libraries to create
nougat packages so that you can have
something in quantum that's is able that
other people are able to use in their
quantum algorithm so you can actually
create
shared quantum libraries with some
quantum stuff inside of that
so let's create an empty applications
let's call it q
sharp i'm going to open it
and i'm going to show you what q sharp
looks like
so it's it's a bit of combination of c
sharp and f sharp basically so it's a
functional programming language
so you should be quite familiar with the
the layout it uses
curly braces it uses operation which is
basically a quantum method
something that you can execute the entry
point
attribute will make sure that this is
the one that's being run
so this operation will automatically be
run like your main method
in your console application this is your
usings from c sharp so
open a namespace to use stuff from that
namespace
and we can begin programming so for
example i want to create
a system that uses one qubit so i'm
going to do using just like in c sharp
when i want to use
resources that need to be disposed of
later i can do using
so q equals a qubit so i'm going to
assign one single qubit
then if you want to put that qubit
through a gate it's just like calling a
function so it's h for the hadamard gate
to put it in superposition on top of my
qubit
now if i want to measure the result of
my qubit i can use that
the measure function for that so m will
do a measurement so that qubit will
collapse with a 50
chance of being zero fifty percent
chance of being one
i can store the result in a variable
called r
so r equals measurement of q
and then i need to reset my qubit
because
q sharp really likes a qubit to be reset
to its original state
so the original state for a qubit will
always be zero so with this operation
i'm
putting it in superposition i'm doing a
measurement on that superposition
i'm resetting the qubit and i'm going to
write
the results to the console with some
string interpolation like c sharp
so i'm just going to do the result to
the console if i do view
terminal i can actually now use
dotnet to run this so dotnet
run this will take it some time to
compile and while it's compiling i can
tell you that
this can actually be run on a real
quantum computer
microsoft is working on azure quantum
and azure quantum
will make sure that you can basically
make a connection from your development
environment to azure quantum
and you can push your algorithms to
azure quantum
that will they that will be able to run
it on an actual quantum computer and the
result will be sent back to you
but right now net is helping us to
create a simulated
environment on your local pc um it will
simulate in the background how these
qubits should interact using a
pseudo-random generator
and it has now generated one as a result
so if i do it again
it should generate still one but it
should actually be a fifty percent
chance of being one and zero so now we
have zero
i'm going to do one modification just to
show you the power of q sharp
and then and then you can see some more
syntax so let's say
i will do this um
[Music]
100 times so from 0 to 100
it's a for loop so i'm going to do
whatever is inside the for loop
100 times like this
i'm going to declare a variable
result which equals zero
i'm going to print out that result in
total
and then when i do the actual
measurement let's say that i'm going to
set
the result to plus equals
r so r is going to be zero or one so i'm
just going to add that number to my
result and then if i do it 100 times
result will be
around 50 because sometimes it's zero
sometimes it's one
it's 50 chance so my results should be
around 50
because i did it 100 times but r is
actually
not a number so i have to do some
conversion so
if r equals 1 then i'm going to add 1 to
that result
otherwise i'm going to add zero to that
result and
so i will do another.net run and this
should actually
give us a number around 50.
so while that is loading i'm going to go
back to my slides
i'm going to talk a little bit about
azure quantum and then i'm already at
the end of my presentation
so azure quantum is actually not yet
available so microsoft is just like ibm
working on a real quantum computer
um and it's going to be used for
optimization machine learning
and also to do some quantum simulation
uh on like a cloud level
microsoft already gives you access to
different quantum hardware so they have
their own hardware where they're still
working on so it's not yet finished
they're also partnered with external
companies like inq and honeywell
and they are using ion traps kind of
quantum computers
they are also part in partnering with
qci
and they're using superconducting
quantum computers i don't have time to
talk about all of these in detail
but tomorrow during the workshop i will
talk about them
more in detail so let's go back to q
sharp
and we can see that it's 60 so it's
around 50 because it's you it's using a
pseudo random generator on your local
machine
so it's always going to be around 50
of course a percent only works when
you're when you're actually running your
algorithm an
infinite amount of times we're now only
running it 100 times
so with that um
my my time is basically basically run
out so i hope
you have seen a glimpse of quantum
computing i hope you have an idea of
of why it can help us um again you can
contact me also after this session
um and tomorrow um there will be a
two-hour workshop where we are going to
actually
do some q sharp development and we will
do some more
examples that are actually meaningful
instead of the thing that i just did